i don't think that the legislation was
passed definitively in the interest of
putting more black people in jail
that's what it did but i don't think joe
biden was sitting in a room legislating
like hell yeah [ __ ] these black people
for sure for sure you know
with the election upon us millions of
americans are gearing up to cast their
vote for the next president of the
united states
while some people will be voting
independent we wanted to hear from trump
voters and biden voters about why they
are voting for their candidate
in spectrum we bring everyday people
together for authentic discussions that
represent what's happening now
these discussions should not be anyone's
sole source forming opinions on
important issues
please do your own research seek out
experts push yourself
outside your bubble and have empathy
thanks for watching
my name is christine and i am 23 years
old and i live in houston texas i think
that the overall civic health of america
is just so
low and i feel like the more we have
these kind of conversations the more
people will start to think for
themselves
hi i'm piper i'm passionate about
decolonization
systemic equality socialism and
environmentalism
my name is pranav khanderi i'm currently
a freshman at the university of texas
at austin it's one of the most
consequential elections of our lifetime
it's going to determine the future of
our country in civil rights human rights
the climate and many other issues across
the board my name is leah thomas and i'm
an environmental activist and the
founder of
the intersectional environmentalist
platform
my name is chris i currently live in
santa barbara california
i think that a vote for joe biden in
this election
is a vote with the idea of prosperity
for all in mind hi
i'm benjamin i work at the democratic
coordinated campaign
and i help lead young asian americans
for biden we cannot afford to be
anything less than passionate as we
fight to protect our families
our friends our communities and our
futures
i'm more anti-trump than pro-biden
piper strongly agree leah
strongly agree pranav strongly agree
benjamin some would disagree chris
strongly agree christine agree
as much as i like absolutely hate trump
there has to be
like young especially young people like
there needs to be that energy there
for biden like i know settle for biden
is huge like well
we'll take him because there's two
choices no this is like literally a
choice between
like destruction of the environment and
our futures
or building towards better progress we
have to be more enthusiastic and we have
to bring
other people along because otherwise
like we're not going to win
definitely agree with what you just said
uh benjamin but at the same time like i
can't deny
like joe biden himself does not make me
respond enthusiastically like i
volunteered for the candidate i
supported in the primary was the first
time i'd ever done it and it was because
i was so
i was driven like i feel like i needed
to at the same time
um i think i would vote for a democratic
ticket if it was literally any other
democratic candidate
i understand the enthusiasm benjamin and
i think the reason why like so
i didn't i voted for warren in the
primary i was very involved with the
campaign
um and like i if i could put anyone in
the white house right now would be her
but i think like the supporting cast is
so important
like like you said i'm voting for a
better future and i don't think that
biden encompasses that entirely
i think that the entire democratic
coalition encompasses that
benjamin you brought up a good point
though um i've like
read a bit about like why hillary
clinton lost in 2016
and a lot of it was because she ran on a
very like anti-trump campaign
because hillary clinton was like a very
hated woman like a lot of people just
don't like her like i have my reasons
for not liking her as well
and her whole campaign was just like
beat trump beat trump be trump and a lot
of people that wasn't enough for them
to get excited behind and so you kind of
made me like
rethink it a little bit but i think also
though we can't get too excited about
him now because we have to still make
sure that there's room for criticism so
we can hold him accountable once he
actually
gets elected joe biden is
too old to be president piper
somewhat disagree leah disagree
pranav disagree benjamin strongly
disagree
chris disagree christine disagree
let's say like all hell did break loose
and like
joe biden is now like just suddenly just
becomes like cognitively incapable of
doing the job
kamala harris she's a beast so i mean
what the vice president's for
you know right i think the only person
who could really say like strongly agree
was is like a pete voter i mean the
person i voted for in the primary was
also like
70 plus so his age kind of also
fits with his like his demeanor or like
his appeal
he is more like a like a grandfather
figure of the
like entire party that age comes with a
lot of experience
and like i think right now we need to
return to some sort of normalcy
i also really hate when people pick at a
stutter that he's had for like his whole
life that is incredibly
ableist yeah the candidate that i was
supporting was older than him and you
know trump's old so
it's fine i believe abortion
is a human right piper
strongly agree leah agree
pranav strongly agree benjamin
strongly agree chris strongly agree
christine agree i feel like there's a
separation of church and state
and people just keep forgetting that i
don't know i don't know why
and also i don't think anyone like likes
abortion and that choice is one that is
incredibly traumatic and hard for i'm
sure a lot of people and
i just really don't like when people are
like well no abortions no sex education
no free contraception no nothing and
it's like there's so many other things
that would actually help decrease the
amount of abortions that are had if we
could get better sex education
in school easier access to contraception
and health care
the word abortion is not in the bible
step one step two
i'm not having an abortion like i don't
i would never do that if i'm in a
situation and i just that's what i
believe but that's not
my job to enforce that on other people
and going back to what you said leah
like sex
education or why not putting so forth
some type of like
grant or something if people decide not
to abort why not
improving the foster care system i mean
they're not giving us any other
options so you want me to have the baby
but you're not going to give me anything
to support it you're not going to
improve minimum wage and you're not
going to do anything in my neighborhood
to make this safe for my child so what's
next
first off i don't believe that life
starts at conception i do not believe it
constitutionally makes sense for a fully
grown woman to be constitutional on the
same level as a
cluster of cells and that they should
give out like they should have to like
sacrifice like
the right to their bodily autonomy the
second thing is also i kind of compare
it to like prostitution
like it's going to happen to some extent
regardless and making it legal and like
having like having there be like
institutions um and like infrastructure
for it to be like
safe and affordable is a lot better
regardless of whether or not someone
thinks that an abortion is good
um you at least want like a woman to be
safe
i think this is one of the biggest
reasons to vote for joe biden
um is because trump has selected a
supreme court nominee who
like is devout at overturning roe v
wade if you support autonomy i think you
have to vote for joe biden
joe biden has a racist past
piper i said agree yeah
i might disagree pranav somewhat
disagree
benjamin someone disagree chris
somewhat disagree christine and what
disagree
i think this just goes back to like what
do we define as
racism but just looking at his policies
which are kind of the only thing we can
go off of like
the 1994 crime bill like it almost
exclusively targeted black
americans i know like he also in the
obama administration they had a lot of
mass deportations
war crimes in the middle east and all
these things put together like
i can't determine like his individual
like opinions but all i can go off of
is his policies and he just has a pretty
racist history
i don't believe that joe biden the
person as an individual
is a racist man um but i do think like
he has had a
history of not making choices that were
the most equitable
but i also think some of those choices
were a result of like the cultural
zeitgeist at the time
and i don't think that joe biden
necessarily should be held to account
for like the worst parts of that
legislation
because i don't think that the
legislation was passed definitively
in the interest of putting more black
people in jail
that's what it did because of the way
everything was structured at the time
like more black people went to jail
but i don't think joe biden was sitting
in a room legislating like hell yeah
[ __ ] these black people for sure for
sure you know
even if which i don't believe to be the
case at all even if he had like some
ball of hatred in his heart
against like communities of color it's
political suicide for him
not to help communities of color as
someone who has worked in the biden
campaign like he has
plans to help like african-american
communities he has plans to help like
asian american and pacific islander
communities they're like on his website
like they're part of the platform we
have like the
the power to hold him to it and say like
we elected you to do these things
like these are the things you promised
us that you would do and now we expect
you because we voted for you
like we expect you to follow through on
those promises
police departments should be defunded
piper strongly agree leah
strongly agree pranav somewhat agree
benjamin some would agree chris
agree and christine somewhat disagree
i feel like there's not like if we were
to defund the police now
there's not structures in place to
reallocate that funding efficiently
like i feel like in order to defund the
police we need to fund
other things first and then we can just
like build a pipeline so that there's
money to go
into wherever we think is best like i
just worry that
like if we were to defund the police now
it would just like get
thrown back into the government and then
it would just like go somewhere else
useless uh
so i say somewhat disagree because like
in houston i'm
a part of like the mayor student
leadership alliance and something we've
talked about with the mayor of houston
is that he doesn't feel like
the police should be defunded but he
feels like the money that's in the
police system right now should go
towards bringing other people into this
system to actually handle the issues
that police are getting called for that
nothing to do with police right
homelessness mental health issues and so
like when i did a lot of like research
and looking at what other
democratic candidates feel like a lot of
those people don't feel like there needs
to be a defunding of the police but
more so a reform of the police structure
and how they facilitate the issue
so i don't think that defunding the
police will lead to better policing
i think for me after the aftermath of
ferguson like which
impacted my hometown i just started
having some questions like why do they
need tanks
why do they need these grenades why are
they at war with
us and that to me just made me take a
step back with some of the equipment and
resources that they have from the
military
and christine i 100 agree and i think
when i support defending the police i
support dismantling the police which is
very different from abolishing the
police even though people like to spin
it as that and to me there's already
been enough police reform
especially since 2014 we've got the
cameras we've got trainings but like
there needs to be some sort of
dismantling or restructuring or
something because
whatever is happening is not working but
of course i would never say get rid of
the police
but i definitely don't think that they
need to have tanks especially if they're
not doing implicit bias training
i think defund the police like has such
a bad connotation to it because it does
sound like this abrupt like take away
all their money but you can't fit a
whole
public policy plan into one slogan
some of the like top like brains
in policy writing that support defunding
the police
don't support just taking away all their
funding and doing nothing with it and i
think honestly
if you reallocate the funds well enough
we won't even need police at all
eventually because why do police exist
because people are committing crimes why
does crime exist
because of poverty because of you know
all these other reasons so i think
obviously not all at once but like if we
gradually reallocate those funds into
other resources
we could get rid of a lot of the things
that even require the need for police
and maybe still have some law
enforcement that exists
but it will not be as big of a thing as
it is now i think that is a very good
point that one a lot of these
terms have like really strong
connotations right so like when leah
said dismantle i was like jesus like but
like not even really like
understanding the perception of this
mantle that she had and so i think i
really strongly agree
that like when we say defund the police
where does that money go
right because in my head when i hear d
from the police i don't think that the
police force is then going to take away
the ability to buy tanks and all these
different things
i immediately think that they're going
to pay cops less right and that's what i
think a lot of people think
because i you know because what does the
fund mean and so this is what concerns
me
because like this is anyone right you
get underpaid for something that you're
really good at and you're like excuse me
so i think that's a really good
conversation to have
i am open to conservative ideas
piper somewhat disagree leah
agree pranav somewhat agree
benjamin agree chris somewhat disagree
christine strongly agree
there are some conservative ideals that
i do respect right like i think that
a lot of what this boils down to is not
the issue itself but the implementation
of the issue like when i went to go look
at
the gun laws that you know the democrat
pyramid candidates were looking at a lot
of candidates were saying that we should
um ban assault rifles and then most of
them said that they're not going to buy
them back
and i'm like okay so we didn't prohibit
this before
some people spent x amount of dollars on
this assault rifle and you're not at
least going to buy it back from them
another thing i think about is like the
social welfare programs right
do i think more people should be
eligible for it yes is there any measure
on a lot of these programs that get
people off of the system integrated back
into the workforce
no so you have people who specifically
take advantage of the system and
specifically take care
take advantage of us as taxpayers i just
i think in life i'm just
generally invested in just giving more
food land crops like money whatever it
is there
there is plenty in the united states we
have the infrastructure to support
everyone in this country like
significantly more than we do currently
warren's wealth tax is something that i
was really really in favor of
and it's not something that those people
are going to miss like it's not like
like
i'm like you're taking their livelihood
from them you're simply
repurposing a part of their livelihood
that they're
honestly probably never going to get the
opportunity to use in the first place
and making it so that other people can
be at least a slingshot
closer so in that respect i think like
conservative ideology tends to be
stingier if you will what america needs
to do more is to compare itself to other
countries and like entities that have
similar wealth like
in my political science class like we're
comparing
the united states to the european union
countries in the eu and large like
provide so many more social services to
their people and their people
are so much happier and their the wealth
gap in america is so
much greater than it is there i'm always
willing to hear
what the other side has to say but like
i'm pretty well versed in politics at
this point and like
i know that like i honestly don't really
agree with any conservative ideals
i think for me there can be like a lot
of unlikely allies
but i think it depends on what the
outcome is
of that conservative thinking like
whether or not i might be opening to
listening to it
so like if they're like okay i really
want to stimulate the economy we need
more jobs
and then the how is through green jobs
and green infrastructure like that's
something that could definitely have
bipartisan support
like i'm talking with a church that is
really passionate
and really wants to take a bold stance
on climate
and if i would have just kind of shut
them out because they do have some
conservative ideologies
then i feel like you know maybe we
wouldn't be able to i guess progress
i don't want my ego to get so big where
i think that the only way to be
is like me but that doesn't justify
policies that lead to the oppression of
other people
that's another there's another situation
but i can have empathy for
for them i believe joe biden
will win this election somewhat agree
some would agree i agree but this is me
knocking on wood
uh somewhat agree strongly agree
agree i'm not willing to let the
universe
think that i believe anything different
and i'm not willing to even let the
words from my mouth escape to
encourage any kind of taking away from
that outcome uh when i get super down in
the dumps i go on twitter to at trump
underscore regrets
and just see posts from people who are
like i can't believe i voted for you in
2016.
i'm voting for biden now and like yeah
dude just to see like how many people
have have defected and uh to even see
the people who hold themselves
accountable in person
like looking now they're like hey i
thought i thought maybe something
different would be
would be by switching it up and not
sending a politician office in 2016. i
am
so sorry it makes me hopeful um that
like
in the same way like a ton of people
have defected from trump
i literally do not see the opposite at
all like i don't see anyone like who's
like previously
like democrat and he's like you know
what [ __ ] it
i'm just gonna vote for trump like no
one is saying that which is like
which makes me like very very very happy
i mean it's i put someone agree because
like it depends like it depends on us
doing the work behind the scenes to like
make that [ __ ] happen
like elections aren't one because like
people get complacent
and so like i don't want people to think
for a day between now and november
third that like we can take our foot off
the pedal
like people are like oh biden is up 15
points nationally and i'm like yeah
hillary was up like five points
nationally and what did that do for her
like we have to just keep working to
make this happen it's just going to be
a fight like literally every single day
from now until election day
that was great you guys hi nice meeting
y'all thank you so much
[Music]